This morning,
only a few days left in Georgia'
Senate runoff.
President Obama will be there to
to campaign
alongside the incumbent
Democratic Senator, Raphael Warn
This is the eve of the final day
of early voting
where voter turnout over
the last
few days has been setting record
I was in Georgia on Monday.
I spoke with some of the Georgia
who were casting those votes
early to talk about
what was at the top of their min
What were they thinking about
when they went to the ballot box
I also had a chance to speak
with Senator Warnock himself.
With the days left in Georgia's
high stakes Senate race.
Voters are swarming polling loca
and shattering early voting reco
What was important to you
as you were in there casting you
Well, the important thing is the
I am concerned about women's rig
civil rights.
More than 1 million
Georgians have already voted,
surpassing early turnout
from past presidential elections
as voters decide
between incumbent
Democratic Senator
Raphael Warnock
and his Republican
challenger, Herschel Walker.
This race is about Georgia.
This race is about
who is going to represent
11 million people
Neither candidate reached the 50
threshold in November,
throwing Georgia
into its second Senate runoff el
since January 2021.
And the outcome
this time will determine
whether Democrats have 50 Senate
seats or 51.
The stakes couldn't be higher.
And the
contrast between me
and my opponent
could not be more obvious.
It is time we get this right.
In a way we get it right.
But put me in the Senate
because I'm not going to dance
and sing for nobody.
I never have and never will.
Both Warnock and Walker are cour
the more than 200,000 Georgians
who voted for Republican Governo
Brian Kemp,
but not Walker,
whose campaign has been plagued
by scandals,
including allegations
that he paid for abortions
despite opposing the procedure.
You saw something
that didn't happen in Georgia.
They split ticket voters.
I think they can see the contras
And I think we're going
to see the results of that next
While Kemp has endorsed Walker,
Warnock is directly
appealing to Kemp's voters
without ads like this one.
At the end of the day,
I have to vote
for someone that I can trust
and that has integrity.
And I don't believe
that is Herschel Walker,
one Georgian
who voted for the Republican gov
but not the Republican Senate ca
Explain to CNN why, just based o
the character that
the interviews
we've had, the type of stuff
that Herschel Walker says,
I'm of the opinion, he'll say
pretty much anything to get elec
Walker enjoys strong name recogn
from his time as a Georgia bulld
But despite winning the Heisman
Trophy in 1982,
some voters
say his accomplishments on the g
shouldn't matter at the polls.
I'm a great fan of Herschel
on the football field.
He has shown me nothing
that would lead me to believe he
a competent senator
to voters
who are supporting Walker in Tue
runoff election.
Say inflation
and the economy were top of mind
But not former
President Trump's endorsement of
Was that a factor?
No, And why not?
Because the Republican Party
is more than President Trump.
Okay. Yeah, we're not all MAGA p
That was
a sentiment
that I heard from other voters
there on the ground in Georgia.
We should note,
we did reach out to the Walker
campaign to interview them,
but they declined.
What did you leave
feeling
because you were there
one week to the day before the e
Georgia voters are sick of runof
They've been voting nonstop
because, you know,
they had that runoff
the last time around with David
Kelly Loeffler.
That's what sent Raphael
Warnock and Jon Ossoff to the Se
They're like this to you.
We've been voting a lot.
We've been very exercising our r
quite often.